hallo und herzlich willkommen wir heute
zu einem neuen video von mir hier sind
es bereits in zivil eingeblendet das ist
meine schwester ich sage ja genau und
das ist julie und julia auf jeden fall
eine sache bei der schwester und jude
ist eine sehr gute freundin von mir und
die beiden machen heute einen quiz
gegeneinander und zwar habe ich zehn
fragen aufgeschrieben über mich die ihr
beiden wissen könnte
und jetzt beide schon jetzt hätte und
tut auch auf jeden fall gehen wir jetzt
die zehn fragen nacheinander durch und
die beiden haben dann zeit um ihre
antwort aufzuschreiben und fahren direkt
an mit der ersten frage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
erste frage hier fangen wir mal ganz
leicht an meine lieben freunde hier leer
julia bist du bereit durch den bürgern
deinen kopf retten sollen
ja was ist mein zweiter name die zeit
läuft
hey das ist nicht auf zeit kino kino
look at ja richtig mein name ist die
lohas ihr beiden volltrottel hier nicht
verstanden habe das ganze ist nicht auf
zeit also ich sage euch einfach die
frage ihr könnt euch kurz gedanken
machen könnt sagen ich denke das ist
blöd wenn ihr dann eure lösung die man
dann in der tat aber es ist zumindest
nicht auf zeit also ich stelle jetzt
nächste frage und ihr könnt euch ruhig
zeit lassen können das aufschreiben dann
sage ich nachher 32 dann präsentiert
ihre lösungen jetzt haben sie auch die
dümmsten
[Musik]
zweite frage freunde was ist meine
lieblingsklamotten marke oder nennt eine
von sehen weil ich glaub ich hab es
keine lieblingsmarke aber zumindest
nicht noch nicht zeigen 32
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich nehme auf wald zeigt es doch dass
man sieht weiß ich gar nicht
also ich habe den fall einer meiner
lieblings marken
[Musik]
kommen wir nun zur frage nummer 3 und
zwar was ist meine lieblingsfarbe
juni nicht abgucken hierbei sarah
derzeit 3 21 und co
bei etwas geld ja in dem buch startet ja
ganz richtig versteht bereits 3
[Musik]
die vierte frage ist gar keine richtige
frage sondern er nenne einen satz den
ich oft sage und dann beraten die sich
die beiden anderen immer ob der satz
wichtig auf gesagt wir ein paar sekunden
später aufgeschrieben und salat auf
geschrieben hallo mein name ist luca
keinen saarburg beleidigung muss ich
alles aussieht wenn ihr noch
ich würde sagen an der stelle geht der
punkt definitiv an sarah baganz das ist
aber kein satz
[Musik]
nächste frage jetzt wird es richtig
schwierig ein welche genaue schuhgröße
trage ich in den meisten meiner schuhe
jetzt hier ab nämlich menschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend ihre teure
lösungen in 321 jetzt wir haben hier 45
und hier 44 einhalb die größte ist 45
ein drittel in sneaker oder 45 23
ich weiß gar nicht genau wie es ist
deswegen absagen kommt näher ran
5 ich muss alles bieten was ihr sagen
natürlich nichts trinken
[Musik]
nächste frage meine sehr verehrten damen
und damen
die frage laute in welchem jahr wurde
ich eingeschult
wisst ihr das vorher allgemeinwissen
präsentiere teure lösungen meine damen
und herren in 321 co
sarah hat was ist das 2003 oder 2003
2003 bis 2002 you got geworden 2002 das
ist doch gar keinen sinn zuerst über
rasten durch nach vierten klassen oder
warum kurz fragen waren wurde ich
eingeschult
sie können sich diese anlage im august
2000 2002 oder nein ich wurde 2006
eigentlich wie wir sie gehabt dass
gerade gesehen freunde meine mutter
meinen auch 2002 also wie gesagt der
punkt geht an julia er wir sehen den
punktestand ja oben eingeblendet
verführt dafür mit einem punkt oder her
[Musik]
nächste frage freunde seid ihr bereit ja
wie groß im ich weiß selbst nicht genau
ich weiß nur dass mein herz steht und
das ist falsch weil ich bin nicht 190
321 go und sondern was sarah hat 188
ich habe 13 9 juli abgebrochen
wieso fokussiert der judas gesicht und
ich meinte ich meine melodie jetzt was
ist mein lieblingsessen
ich habe zwei lieblingsessen oder drei
mit pizza 4
ich habe vier lieblingsessen dh an
dieser stelle können tatsächlich auch
mehrere antworten richtig sein weil ich
ein mensch bin sehr sehr sehr sehr gerne
ist und ich würde sagen resultiere teure
lösungen in 321 jetzt das war das hat
auch die fenster sarah hat hähnchen
curry aufgeschrieben und du hast pizza
und rüttelt die hitze trifft irgendwas
pizzas und gesagt gerade das geht nicht
ja und nein hast du nicht würde den
punkt eigentlich eher sagen hallo pizza
pizza ist auch eine ja okay ich sehr
freundlich sagen der punkt geht an sarah
okay der punkt dann beide
[Musik]
jetzt im kontrast zu der frage die ich
euch vorhin gestellt haben endet ein
nett doch nennt moment einen essens
produkt sag ich jetzt mal was ich über
alles hasse
wieso schreibt ihr nicht ist ein
dummkopf lösungen 321 zeigen
zwiebel stimmt cocos fokus da okay an
der stelle muss ich sagen ich gebe dir
er den punkt als sarahs wiebel mag ich
jetzt auch nicht so unfassbar gern aber
der grund warum warum ich das meisten
der der grund warum ich das meistens ich
bestelle das einfach weil man danach
stinkt das warum habt ihr nicht pilze
aufgeschrieben habe komme ich jetzt
keinen profi zwiebeln 1 aufgehellt
nein
[Musik]
letzte frage an sarah und an jule einem
ist die letzte möglichkeit dass sarah
hier wirklich irgendwie ausgleichen kann
sagt wie oft ich bereits in amerika war
[Musik]
was sind ihre teure lösungen vier mal
vier punkte dann keinen dreimal stimmt
thomas selber nachdenken über dann dumme
fragen ich war einfach mit einem
kollegen in new york dann war ich mit
tobi in new york und in den eltern war
ich nur mit ilja und dann geht man ja
nie ja stimmt 4
okay wir machen auch eine allerletzte
frage
ich habe mir jetzt noch eine allerletzte
frage überlegt im juli führt mit einem
punkt und ich würde sagen dass diese
letzte fragen und alles entscheiden
[Musik]
julia hat diese zehn fragen eigentlich
gewonnen wäre das video allerdings
gewinnt ist der diese fragen richtig
beantwortet und zwar gibt diese frage
10.000 punkte meine damen und herren was
war der erste fifa teil den ich mir
gekauft habe
ihr wisst ja dass es bei fifa so ist das
immer fifa steht und dann das ja also
wenn in welchem jahr in welchem fifa ja
ich mit den ersten teil gekauft ist ein
gutes sagen meine damen und herren
präsentiert ihre lösungen 3 oder jetzt
13 11 ich bin näher dran sarahs näherin
ja jetzt ist vielfach 2006 gewesen an
der stelle würde ich sagen es war ein
wirklich ein hartes hartes
kopf-an-kopf-rennen
julia hat eigentlich geworden allerdings
hauptsache die letzte frage geworden
schreibt ihr die kommentare was habt ihr
seine schwester ist wer sich dessen
wissen dass er sich als weitere linie um
spaß das ist eine frage dass er komplett
nicht gerecht hier
du kannst du dich traust ein jude ist
jetzt raus gegangen zum glück hier
würden an der stelle jetzt das ganze
video beenden da ist ja wieder ein bild
führt euch das video gefallen haben das
gerne mal leiter freuen
die kommentare was hier eventuell
gedacht hätte man den bestimmten sachen
soll ich das ganze eventuell nochmal
machen vielleicht mit welchen anderen
leuten und sonst will ich das video
ich hab die letzten worte
das was jetzt hier vom video das war's
jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken hier findet ihr zwei andere
videos und managen abonnent seid könnt
ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]